JUSTINE: Hey guys, how's it going! Happy Holidays! It's another video about
The festive season.
JENNA: I have a hot glue gun.
JUSTINE: Today, we are going to decorate holiday iPhone cases, so you got two cases here,
JUSTINE: I have a really cute little folio case and you've got -- JENNA: Oh, wait. How is that...
JENNA: fair I only have one side?
JUSTINE: You got... Your right. JENNA: "iJustine". More like "I Just Cheat"
JUSTINE: This isn't a competition, this is fun...yeah.
JENNA: You're being super drunk. JUSTINE: Shall I show you what I had to feel? JENNA: Don't touch me. JUSTINE: So we've got a bunch of craft supplies.
JENNA: We also set up those theatres chips. JUSTINE: We do. JENNA: Not sponsored, just for fun.
JUSTINE: Oh, I love cookie dough. JENNA: Nick loves when we crunch right in the mic...this is not sponsored.
I'm not good.
Already did, that great. I have no idea what is happening. You're blocking my shot beacuse, like, what is this? What is this?
JENNA: What actually is it? Alright I know what I want to do. JUSTINE: OH, look at this. This is very FANCY. JENNA: HAVE A HOLLY -- JUSTINE: JOLLY....CHRISTMAS.
That's a little bit...
That's a little aggressive -- JENNA: YOU'RE a little aggressive.
JUSTINE: Yes. This key to holiday decorations is to really think outside the box. JENNA: I could really think regular box.
JUSTINE:  Oh my Gosh, these are so super cute. JENNA: This is making me so upset. JUSTINE: Okay this is blinking. don't do that. Don't do that-- no Jenna!
Oh, my gosh. These were on sale at Target. JENNA: Here's the thing you're left-handed, right?
JUSTINE: Yes. JENNA: Doesn't that mean you use the part of your brain that makes you creative?
JUSTINE: Yeah but I'm using my right hand, right now. JENNA: So that means you're using your whole brain
which means you're more creative than me. JUSTINE: That's true. JENNA: Oh man... OH JESUS! That was the late burn!
JUSTINE: You gotta be careful! JENNA: It like, touched me, but I didn't realize that because my - my neurons were a little slow...
and then it just shook me like a
hurricane. *singing together*
JENNA: What - what else have you got in this whole pack?
JUSTINE: What you got in that pack? *singing together again*
JENNA: I'm  just - I'd like to apologize to everyone who's made it this far in the video and nothing has happened yet.
JUSTINE: Ow, my finger is burning. Hot to touch.
this is - this is what we... JENNA: No, shut up - it's going to be fabulous!
JUSTINE: Okay, I believe it. I think I'm getting real into DIY like "Doing It Myself", doing it - yourself. JENNA: I need more things.
JENNA: I don't know... *mouths, I need help*
JUSTINE: Okay, well, you know, you do whatever you think that you need to do to make it great.
JENNA: I have no idea what I need to. Can -- I would like to start over. Can we start the video over? JUSTINE: The heck?
JENNA: Redo. Mulligan.
JUSTINE: What's that mean?
JENNA: *sighs* How come my glue isn't being hot? JUSTINE: Even - I dont think I want to do it myself anymore.
Alexa! Play "everybody hurts"
JENNA: This is - this is like how I feel right now. JUSTINE: I know. JENNA: Really sad. Because I lost, again at a "not" competition.
JUSTINE: Alexa stop!
I'm gonna get a copyright strike. JENNA: I was just getting into it. Just don't love my creative direction here. It's trash.
JUSTINE: How long will we've been rolling? CAMERMAN: 44 minutes.
JUSTINE: I've been gluing these freaking things down for 45 minutes? JENNA: Have we really?It feels like for freaking EVER.
JUSTINE: It feels like for freaking ever. JENNA: These little gems - I'm looking for symmetry and they're hard to match up. JUSTINE: Hmm symmetry.
JENNA: I like symmetry -- I like symmetry and I like following the rules. JUSTINE: Awhoo. You sound like a goody two - shoes. JENNA: I'm fun.
JUSTINE: *mocks Jenna* "Oh, hey guys you want to follow the rules and have a fun time?"
JENNA: Symmetrical fun. JUSTINE: "Call Jenna!"
I'd give you her number, but I don't know it! JENNA: You don't know my number? What if there's an emergency?
JUSTINE: I guess I could jam some gems in. JENNA: I never liked doing arts and crafts in school.
Did you? JUSTINE: Of course I did. I'm right brained. JENNA: Sometimes you're like -- no brained. No, you're fine. JUSTINE: *screeches* God, this is hot!
Mmmmmmm -- Mother FLAMING!
FIRECRECKERS FOREVER. JENNA: What? JUSTINE: Jheez! OW OW OW!
Gracious glory! JENNA: *sings* Everybody hurts.
JUSTINE: I hope you're having fun.
Look at the symmetry. JENNA: Well, it's not symmetrical as I can't find it. Well. Are we done yet?
Because yeah... JUSTINE: Yeah, I could do this all night, and - I'm - it's already like, freakin' midnight. JENNA: I think it's the morning now. Alright, here we go!
It's an iPhone. It's the case, it's a necklace. It's fashion. JUSTINE: Oh, that's cute!
Mine, um - willl get you through a dark night.
Um - when you walk to your car, and you're like "where's ma keys?" -- JENNA: Hey, this isn't fair! You've had two parts that decorate!
JUSTINE: It's -  yeah, but it had more surface area that I had to cover.
Yeah, but like,  you had more options like I  - I have this.
I'm putting myself in the freezer, I quit.
JUSTINE: You should go in there, i'll see you in a couple of years. I'll come - i'll come.
"Let's see what she's doing!" She comes out - and she still has her like,
2018...
JENNA: These are still lit - kept me warm, I didn't actually freeze. JUSTINE: Oh boy.
JENNA: That was Justine!
This is terrible. JUSTINE: Ow. Let me see it on you. Yours isn't a necklace. You're a loser.
Come on it's lovely whether for an iPhone...
Decorating together with you -- JENNA: You know it looks better further away. I've been looking at it close up and
I'm like "oh" but wow-y from far away. It's glamorous. JUSTINE: Mmm. JENNA: Super good, super glam. I can let you borrow it.
I can let you borrow it because it's "J".
JUSTINE: How many songs have we sang? In like - like, everything that we do, there's a song for it. JENNA: Mine's better.
I won this competition. JUSTINE: Okay. Well. We're not - this isn't a competition. Unless YOU guys want to make it a competition.
JENNA: I won. JUSTINE: let us know in the comments below who you think is the best. I will also put a poll right up here...
JENNA: You could do that? JUSTINE: Yeah. And let us know whose you think it better. JENNA: Guys please, mine's a necklace.
It's a necklace. It's a carrier. JUSTINE: Or do you think Jenna's looks better? JENNA:
It's a noisemaker. JUSTINE: Can you get a shot at -- can you see a close up? Can you see how good this looks? JENNA: *mouths trash*
JUSTINE: Yeah, that looks great...
Like, mine even opens up....
JENNA: That's - that's the disadvantage. You chose the case, you gave me this one. JUSTINE: Look, it also blinks.
JENNA: You're an idiot. You gave me -- JUSTINE: You're ruining the Christmas spirit. You're a Grinch. JENNA: No, I love Christmas but YOU -
Admit that you took the case that you knew, you could make better than mine.
JUSTINE: *crunch crunch* JENNA: Joke's on you because the poll's gonna be like "Jenna's looks beautiful". JUSTINE: Can't hear you because I'm crunching.
I'm gonna send this clip to Matt. JENNA: He's not gonna like it. JUSTINE: Guys, listen I have a task for you.
JENNA: Oh no! JUSTINE: This is very important. Go, find something super crunchy. Eat it and then tweet it to @nadeshot.
JENNA: He's not gonna be happy JUSTINE: And tell him "Merry Christmas". JENNA: He's not gonna like that at ALL. JUSTINE: It's gonna be the best thing ever!
JENNA: Oh, and this is also an instrument! JUSTINE: We're ending this video. That's bad for the microphone.
You're ruining -- JENNA: I'M ruining -- JUSTINE: Christmas. Christmas has been ruined.
Okay guys - thanks for watching. Happy Holidays! If you guys decide to make a festive...
Holiday case for a friend or for yourself
Please tweet it to me or Jenna.
Tweet it to us both. We wanna see 'em. And let us know who's case you like at the best.
And yes, I may, have had a slight advantage. I didn't even realise it.
JENNA: *laughs*  JUSTINE: Aww, buddy. *laugh together*
Bye. *laughs again* Stop, stop this right now. We're done.